so now let's consider how we apply the
how we test to initial coin offerings
and we can just run down the checklist
remember an initial coin offering is a
situation where you're going to be
sending crypto to a third party based on
a white paper
and you're going to get code in return
and you're going to hope that that code
winds up being worth more once the
system gets launched
and you're able to actually sell that
crypto to other people are going to be
able to use it in the system
well let's go down the checklist is
there an investment of money you betcha
all right the crypto that you invest
counts as money
is there commonality
well you've got horizontal commonality
you're pooling your money with other
people have bought the same ico
you clearly have
vertical commonality in the broad sense
because you're relying on the promoter
and you also have it in the narrow sense
because the promoter is keeping a piece
of that crypto for itself as well
so the promoters interests are highly
correlated with your own interest so an
investment of money in a common
enterprise is there an expectation of
profit of course there is
again it's not like the orange you're
not buying the crypto in most situations
in order to be able to use the crypto
you're buying it because you're hoping
to sell it to someone else at a price
higher than the price at which you paid
it and also
at the time that you're buying it the
crypto doesn't even really exist yet you
have a right to the crypto and the
crypto isn't even useful so if you're
asking yourself is this crypto something
that's primarily for consumption
purposes or for investment purposes
it's not even a conversation there is no
consumption purpose there's nothing you
can use it for it's only good for
investment so we've got an investment of
money in a common enterprise expectation
of profits coming primarily from the
effort of others
you're a passive investor you've put in
the money you've bought the crypto now
you've got to hope that the people who
have taken your
bitcoin
will actually do something productive
with the bitcoin and build a system that
works so the thousand dollars that you
spent on that bitcoin becomes a million
dollars which is the reason why you
invested
and is there an alternative regulatory
regime
doubtful there's no federal crypto
agency uh
it's chaos
so if you look at the existing supreme
court precedent in this space
and what you say is the court has always
deferred to other regimes when they're
clearly in place there's nothing else
that's clearly in place here
so a straightforward application
of the five factor how we test
leads pretty conclusively to the
conclusion that the vast majority of
icos
are securities they can therefore be
regulated by the sec
they therefore have to be registered or
you have to find an exemption the vast
majority of these
offerings do not qualify for exemptions
which means that if they're not
registered they're violating the federal
securities laws and if they wind up
lying in any material way for example by
making representations in a white paper
as to how the code works and the code
doesn't work that way
you got problems
serious problems